MSNBC has hired Robert Gibbs who was
President Obama's press secretary and
David Axelrod who is his chief campaign
officer and they are now working as
analysts on MSNBC now before you jump
down my throat
yes Fox News has hired Sarah Palin in
the past and Newt Gingrich so yes maybe
they're just being as bad as them but
should progressives be a little bit
better that's where I'm gonna start this
thing Aaron loaded up everything
honest to god there's no like it's so
split everything is so split and now the
media is completely i watch MSNBC like a
couple it would be refreshing now and
then if someone's like what I remember
like I'm Rachel Maddow a couple weeks
ago she's like what's going on with the
drones and that secret report and I
thought wow we haven't heard one like
call Obama out like I think maybe in the
last you know couple of years so I mean
but but they also the flip side is like
if I want to get you know throw a bomb
under the bus you had Fox if I want to
get this is you know pro-democratic oh
well hit MSNBC and then one time I was
like I'm gonna watch the nightly news I
want to see what my parents are getting
and it was like you know 20 minutes on a
chicken farm and you know what I mean it
really is like you got to pick your it's
like cheerleading you know which yeah
it's ridiculous
where does it leave CNN if they're if
MSNBC is gonna go down the route that
Fox has gone down just the other side
where does that leave that network that
people used to trust that now nobody
watches where are they I don't know I
can't stand Wolf Blitzer the minute he
comes on I used to love CNN I mean back
in the day they were the ones they were
hiding under the bed and the you know in
the Iraq war a CNN wants to be this
middle ground but it's just it's mushy
it's it's it's like a big mushy peat
moss bog there's nothing there the
Fourth Estate it's gone it's disappeared
there's there's no one deciding how to
filter this information there's I mean
you know where
Edward r murrow ever said you know I
blame I mean we've got Reagan who undid
a lot of it you know with the fairness
fairness doctrine went away then Clinton
and the Communications Act let all these
corporations buy all this media up the
conglomerates it's all about eyes and
it's all about ratings it's not about
information anymore so you know what at
least the bias is front and center now
before you have to educate people and
say oh the mute the net then the nightly
news is biased the New York Times
actually is biased now it's like of
course it's biased except people don't
think it's biased people who liberals
watch MSNBC think that's the truth and
the conservatives watch Fox and thinks
that's the truth and they're both
screwed yes I actually think it's
dangerous that we constantly are
reinforcing the very things that we
believe and never challenging any of
those we get gridlock in Washington I
wonder why
sometimes I go like three shows in like
edge Rachel Maddow and then like three
shows in and I'm just like yeah come and
then I'm just like all right I get so
riled up and then I think well there's
also an other opinions out there there's
other and the thing is like yeah I'm
like a pretty intense Democrat but I
know my party's got major issues like I
also would like to sit down with like a
normal Republican learn I want to be
informed I know there's like and that's
why it's so sad because there should be
a coming together of great ideas on the
Republican side and the Democratic side
that's how it should work and that's
that's we need a three-party system I
Minnesota thing I think we absolutely
yeah to work and acts good for him he's
a political consultant made good let him
go make some money now and tout is his
administration and I think it's great
but but we have lost the objectivity and
in media and that's sad and Fox started
it and MSNBC's around give that balance
and CNN was there but now CNN is gonna
go entertainment and so you're gonna
have to go to newspapers or stations or
networks like RT Russian television BBC
that are actually
very objective I think those are gonna
stash is amazing gotta start being the
alternative for people who are publican
are you telling us to go to Russian TV
and Al Jazeera was interviewed by David
Frost on al Jazeera yeah I'm a loyal
follower of that Network and they're
they're much more impartial than our
networks are yeah yeah now interestingly
you really suffered from this this
partisan and corporate conglomerate news
controlled everything because you polled
at one point to get into one of the Fox
News debates and everybody was saying
the entire election cycle oh we need a
Republican who socially moderate and
more okay with abortion or gay rights
that kind of stuff but who's you know
fiscally conservative and strong for
defense which was precisely what your
platform was and Fox News was still
pushing you on the outside so that just
goes to show how partisan the the news
organization my when I speculate is that
Romney had something to do with that I
was very much going after Romney which
is why I was on Rachel Maddow a lot
because I pointed out a lot of his
shortcomings and a lot of contradictions
and and Fox left me off and I think the
Romney campaign threatened that he would
be not participating if that debate if I
was there because I was in that position
to point out some of his problems so
that's my suspicion I don't know Fox
necessarily did it of their own accord
but I think that the opponents that I
was running against might've had
something to do with it yeah and it
looks like Romney's probably gonna be a
fox news contributor now so that's sort
of bringing this thing and don't forget
bonobos com is the official outfitter of
the Reuben report and errcode Reuben
report for twenty percent off your first
purchase